in January of 2022 the underwater
volcano hungatanga hunga haha Pai
produced the biggest atmospheric
explosion seen in modern history
scientists have had their eyes on this
volcano ever since an eruption in 2015
joined two islands together
this recent eruption blew that bridge
apart
inundating Islands in Tonga with floods
and a coat of Ash and dust
detectors around the world picked up the
pressure wave from hungatanga hunga pie
people in Alaska could hear the blast
and tsunami waves triggered an oil spill
in Peru
scientists are still untangling all the
ways the eruption rippled through the
Earth ocean and atmosphere
using a network of instruments from
microparometers to hydrophones and
seismometers researchers characterized
the impact of the eruption
the main eruption resulted in shaking
similar to a magnitude 5.8 earthquake
sound waves in various frequencies from
audible sound to infrasound reverberated
around the world
one type of pressure wave that Disturbed
the atmosphere called a lamb wave
circled the Earth six times in four days
this is similar to what was observed
from one of the deadliest volcanic
eruptions in recorded history the 1883
eruption of Krakatoa Indonesia
Lake Tonga the 1883 eruption also
triggered tsunamis around the world
researchers suspected interactions
between the atmosphere and ocean could
have triggered the land waves but didn't
have the data to back it up
then came the Tonga eruption a perfect
opportunity for scientists to understand
these tsunamis using modern day sensors
most tsunamis we see are ordinary
tsunamis disturbances like earthquakes
or landslides move large amounts of
water creating waves
waves caused by the displacement of
water near the volcano moved throughout
the Pacific Ocean and tsunami warning
systems accurately predicted when they
would arrive
but another kind of tsunami a driven
tsunami eluded Warning Systems arriving
two hours before these ordinary waves a
pressure wave Rippling through the
atmosphere was strong enough to move
water creating driven waves that were
small but traveled all around the world
these different types of waves from the
eruption meant the Tonga tsunami lasted
longer than earthquake-induced tsunamis
in addition to waves moving across the
world the eruption shot a giant plume of
water vapor and gas into the sky
at its peak the plume was 57 kilometers
high that's more than triple the height
of a commercial flight and the tallest
ever measured by a satellite
most volcanic plumes deposit lots of Ash
dust and sulfur dioxide into the
troposphere but only the most energetic
ones penetrate higher into the upper
atmosphere
these aerosols temporarily cool the
Earth by reflecting solar radiation from
the Sun back to space
but Tonga was unique the significant
amount of water in the plume meant less
sulfur dioxide and a lot more water made
its way into the stratosphere
one set of researchers used data from
weather balloons to measure how much
water vapor made it high into the sky
they estimate that 50 million tons of
water vapor were spewed into the
stratosphere equivalent to over 19
000 Olympic-sized swimming pools
that means water vapor in the
stratosphere increased by at least five
percent
while the dust and sulfur dioxide
reflects radiation The increased water
vapor acts as a greenhouse gas that
traps Heat
water vapor also sticks around in the
atmosphere longer than aerosols which
means scientists are uncertain whether
the eruption will ultimately cool or
heat the Earth
as researchers continue to analyze the
Treasure Trove of data from the eruption
they hope to create better Warning
Systems and models to anticipate the
impact of future volcanic eruptions
[Music]
foreign